ich glaube das ist ein riesengroßes
Problem unserer Gesellschaft ist halt
diese
unfassbar schreckliche Doppelmoral des
Menschen halt einfach hingehen und sagen
oh Porno pfui pfui da sprechen wir mal
nicht drüber aber sich dann auf der
anderen Seite beschweren wenn dann halt
irgendwelche schlimmen Dinge passieren
[Musik]
13 Fragen hier kommt die erste muss die
Pornoindustrie stärker reguliert werden
wenn ihr sagt ja dann bitte aufs
Grünefeld gehen und wenn ihr sagt eher
nicht dann bitte aufs gelbe Feld
[Musik]
wunderbar jetzt wissen wir wo ihr steht
Frage ist wo steht ihr im Grunde hat ja
jeder Mensch in jedem Alter unbegrenzten
Zugriff auf Pornos aller Art youporn
pornhub xhamster wie sie alle heißen die
meisten Inhalte sind kostenlos und eine
zuverlässige Altersverifizierung gibt es
nicht im Grunde ist das auch gar nicht
so schlimm sagen die einen denn Pornos
die ihn ja in erster Linie dem Vergnügen
der Unterhaltung und vielleicht sogar
der sexuellen Aufklärung und in Sachen
Jugendschutz bringen Verbote schon mal
gar nichts naja sagen die anderen so
einfach ist es nicht wir müssen zum
Beispiel verhindern dass Kinder Hardcore
Videos schauen mit dann entsprechenden
Konsequenzen für die eigene Sexualität
und über sexistische und
gewaltverherrlichen Inhalte haben wir da
noch gar nicht gesprochen die große
Frage ist also braucht es eine strengere
staatliche Regulierung dieser
Pornoindustrie und wenn ja wie könnte
sie aussehen meine Gäste heute sind sich
bei dem Thema natürlich erstmal uneins
die spannende Frage am Ende dieser Folge
wird sein schaffen wir es Brücken
zwischen diesen beiden Positionen und
vielleicht sogar einen Kompromiss zu
finden jetzt erstmal die Frage an euch
wo würdet ihr Euch positionieren auf der
grünen Seite oder auf der gelben
schreibt uns gerne in den Kommentare die
Regeln sind ja einigermaßen klar wenn
ihr der Gegenseite in einem Punkt
zustimmt dann seid ihr herzlich
eingeladen einen Schritt auf die
Gegenseite zuzugehen und wenn ihr sagt
im Grunde finde ich deine Argumentation
gar nicht so schlecht aber in dem Punkt
erzählst du wirklich mist dann könnt ihr
auch gerne Schritt zurückgehen mein Ziel
wäre es möglichst viele von euch am Ende
dieser Folge hier im sogenannten
kompromissfeld zu versammeln mal sehen
wo ihr heute so landet also ich bin
gespannt 13 Fragen habe ich hier kommt
die Frage Nummer zwei und die geht an
Patty du bist Pornodarstellerin und da
könnte man ja eigentlich denken du bist
für einen total freien Zugang zu
pornografischen Inhalten bist du aber
nicht warum ich finde Pornografie ist
wichtig
für die Gesellschaft
stehe ich definitiv dahinter aber nicht
für Kinder und ich möchte da auch ganz
klar unterscheiden ich mache einen
Unterschied zwischen Kinder und
Jugendlichen ich finde das
definitiv ist reguliert werden muss wer
sich es anschauen kann ein komplettes
Verbot halte ich für völligen Bullshit
also das funktioniert gar nicht aber es
muss irgendeine Regulation stattfinden
exzessiver Pornokonsum für Jugendliche
und Minderjährige halte ich für
extremst schwierig und auch wirklich
gefährlich
die Problematik die wir einfach haben
alles was wir haben Porno sehen ist
nicht real es ist gespielt und natürlich
ist Analsex oder andere Sexualpraktiken
wie BDSM keine normale Sexpraktik die
man unbedingt mit 15 16 oder 17
ausprobieren sollte beim ersten mal du
hast es jetzt geschafft innerhalb eines
Statements drei Leute schon da vorne zu
bewegen immer auch du verdienst ja Geld
mit Erotik Inhalten du stehst aber auf
der gelben Seite kannst du ihre
Argumentation
bist du in Teilen gefolgt aber offenbar
nicht ganz wieso nicht ich sehe zum
Beispiel es wichtiger dass wir eine
Medienkompetenz entwickeln dass wir dem
Jugendlichen und Kindern beibringen wie
gehen Sie an Pornos ran und nicht zu
sagen wir verbieten sie komplett oder
wir regulieren ist ich finde generell
ist ja sollte dafür gesorgt werden dass
wir wissen was bedeutet Konsens was
bedeutet ja Verhütung für mich hat ein
Pornos eine ganz ganz wichtige Rolle in
meiner sexuellen Entwicklung weil ich zu
Hause selber keine Aufklärung genießen
durfte und deswegen habe ich mir Pornos
angeguckt um zu wissen was passiert dort
wie sieht Sexualität aus und ich habe
auch gelernt wie zum Beispiel
verschiedene Vulven Aussehen ich habe
dadurch gelernt dass meine Vulva gut so
ist wie sie ist und ich mich nicht
sorgen muss und das haben wir Pornos auf
jeden Fall beigebracht das ist auch ja
gute Seiten gibt und dass ich meinen
Körper dadurch mehr lieben kann und
nicht nur abstoßen kann ich würde gerne
mal Alex ins Spiel holen der vielleicht
auch mal aus deiner eigenen Erfahrung
erzählen kann wie wie bist du mit Pornos
in Zusammenhang gekommen was hat das mit
dir gemacht was hat das für Auswirkungen
auf deine Sexualität gehabt als junger
Mensch also mit elf hätte ich das erste
Pornoheft mit zwölf habe ich dann
blöderweise eine Person verloren in
meinem Leben die mir sehr nahe stand hat
unglaublichen Schmerz verursacht und das
hat mich halt weiter in diese Welt
reingezogen weil es mich halt gut fühlen
lassen mir Pornos reinzuziehen zu
welchen Problemen hat es geführt nur
deshalb krasse Pornosucht Porno und auch
Sexsucht ich glaube dass die
Pornoindustrie stärker reguliert werden
sollte
weil die Gefahren fielen nicht klar sind
und ähm vor allen Dingen der Diskurs
über eine Regulierung ist wichtig wenn
der Regulierung damals schon da gewesen
wäre sprich also irgendwelche Hürden
dann hätte ich vielleicht mehr darüber
nachgedacht ich weiß nicht ob es mich
zwingend gestoppt hätte also ich hätte
meine Wege gefunden ich glaube das
Jugendliche die ihre Wege heute auch
finden werden wenn die Regulierung da
ist aber es regt zum Nachdenken an uns
auf jeden Fall ein Teil der Besserung du
warst also lost und hat es nicht das
Bewusstsein dafür dass es eventuell
problematisch sein könnte nee weil das
Problem ist ja wenn du in deinem Kumpel
Männerkreis irgendwie oder in einem
Jugendlichen buddy-kreis bist und sagst
du ja ich gucke ziemlich viel Pornos und
ich glaube ich habe ein ich glaube ich
habe hier ein Problem wie ist das bei
euch dann sagen die meisten auch aus
Unwissenheit ach command stellt nicht so
an wir gucken das alle und wir finden
das alle geil und
ja dann bist du an dem Punkt wo du
relativ wenig hinterfragst und zu spät
vielleicht auch hinterfragst und dass
das hätte ich mir für mich gewünscht
dass ich eher an den Punkt gekommen wäre
wo vielleicht mal irgendwer gesagt hätte
so Alex dann Konsum das ist vielleicht
ganz schön krass also du hast dir eine
Form von Regulierung deswegen gleich
noch drüber was das genau sein könnte
hättest Du Dir gewünscht aber Umut haben
damit nicht überzeugt dass nach hinten
gegangen warum mittlerweile sogar zwei
Sachen also das erste ist deine
Erfahrungen in allen Ehren und ich habe
Respekt davor dass Du Dich hier outest
und so ehrlich bist wir haben die
Diagnose Pornosucht nicht stimmt das ist
ein Ding was mich in dieser
gesamtdiskussion also nicht hier sondern
im Internet quasi durchaus stört das
einfach eine Begrifflichkeit
auch sehr polemisch genutzt wird und
sehr politisch auch genutzt wird die dir
aber nicht so haben als Diagnose das ist
das eine und das andere ist ich weiß
nicht ob das ein netter Rückblick
deinerseits ist das hätte mir damals
geholfen wie viele Menschen werden denn
substanzabhängig obwohl wir alle wissen
dass die Gefahr einer Abhängigkeit
besteht ab dem ersten Moment wo man das
ausprobiert und trotzdem werden diese
Menschen abhängig auch wenn Sie wissen
die Gefahr besteht und die machen
einfach weiter weil versucht wird dieser
Kick dass man den irgendwie erreicht
Zugänge zur Pornografie zu regulieren
wird sehr wahrscheinlich Erwachsene eher
in die Illegalität treiben und
Jugendliche nicht davor schützenden
Kontakt mit Pornos zu kommen natürlich
gibt es einzelne Menschen die an
problematischen Umgang mit Pornografie
haben das will ich gar nicht absprechen
aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass
nicht das Medium Porno das Problem ganz
oft ist sondern den interpretiere ich
das und wie gehe ich damit um jetzt
sprechen wir gerade über
Begrifflichkeiten und Definitionen
Sexsucht und so weiter Heike ist weit
nach hinten gegangen ich habe da eine
gewisse konstrukturierung aber von
Sexualtherapeut zu Sexualtherapeutin was
entgegnest du zwanghaftes sexuelles
Verhalten ist von der WHO aufgenommen
worden als Diagnose und
dementsprechend wird auch weitere
Forschung hinzugefügt und es wird die
nächste
verhaltensucht sein es ist
verhaltensüchte ist in den Köpfen viele
Menschen in der Bevölkerung und auch von
Therapeuten noch nicht gut bearbeitet
und noch nicht gut vorhanden und ich
sehe Kollateralschäden nämlich von
zwanghaften Süchtigen sexuellen
impulsiven Verhaltensweisen tagtäglich
in meiner Praxis und ja inwiefern in dem
Klienten mit hohem Leidensdruck meine
Hilfe in Anspruch nehmen die
Pornoindustrie muss stärker reguliert
werden weil es viele Kollateralschäden
gibt im Bereich der Gesundheit von
Kinder und Jugendlichen aber auch von
Erwachsenen die leichte Verfügbarkeit
von Pornografie kann einerseits eben zur
Suchtentwicklung beitragen mit starken
persönlichen Konflikten in der Beziehung
gesundheitlichen Konflikten erektile
Dysfunktion orgasmusverzögerung
partnerbezogene Unlust finanzielle
Schwierigkeiten und eben auch berufliche
Komplikationen dass man eben nicht
ausgeschlafen zur Arbeit kommt oder das
Studium nicht fertig bekommt also
unabhängig ganz ganz um und gleich ganz
unabhängig von offiziellen Diagnosen und
Definitionen kannst du nachvollziehen
dass es problematische Bereiche
innerhalb der pornografiekonsums gibt
sie gerade beschrieben hat jein jein
weil das problematische in der Regel ist
nicht dass man Pornos konsumiert warum
haben wir keine horrorfilmsucht als
Diagnose da wollen Menschen auch
irgendeine Kick haben warum haben wir
nicht extrem Sportsucht als Diagnose das
Problem ist die Selbstbefriedigung und
dass die Menschen den Eindruck haben ich
kann mich nicht mal gegen diesen inneren
Drang wären und ich kann da nicht so
ganz mitgehen weil du selber sagst das
stimmt die neue Diagnose die wir haben
ist zwanghafte sexuelle
Verhaltensstörung aber du hast schon
wieder den sucht Begriff mit
reingeworfen hat die WHO nicht
expliziten Statement abgegeben und
gesagt wir distanzieren uns wir holen
Pornosucht nicht als Begriff und
Diagnose mit rein wir haben dafür
keinerlei Daten es ist erste und
zweitens die Forschung sagt eindeutig
das finde ich viel viel spannender dass
gerade
PsychotherapeutInnen die Sucht im
Zusammenhang mit Sex und Pornos
verwenden eher die sind die religiösere
Tendenzen oben und moralische Einwände
gegenüber Sexualität und Pornos das ist
der Stand vielleicht ein Profit davon
natürlich Antworten also da vielleicht
nur dazu ja ich habe Zero religiösen
Hintergrund Zero politischen Hintergrund
ich sehe die Leute in meiner Praxis und
das seit 20 Jahren Gaming des order war
auch eine impulskontrollstörung als
zwanghafte Störung zugeordnet und das
Bewusstsein für Verhaltens Süchte
entsteht langsam und Gaming des orders
die erste anerkannte faltensucht
zwanghafte sexuelle Störungen was sind
denn zwanghafte sexuelle Störung ja also
die Klienten die entwickeln über eine
lange Zeit hinweg über
Toleranzentwicklung Dosissteigerung das
Stadium des Kontrollverlust mit
weitreichenden
Kollateralschäden im Beruf im
persönlichen Dasein in Beziehungen in
der Sexualität also auch gesundheitliche
Störungen da möchte ich gerne darauf
aufmerksam machen weil sucht und sex ist
etwas
und doppelt Charme behaftet ist das
heißt da wird oftmals nicht im
öffentlichen Rahmen drüber gesprochen
und deswegen möchte ich auch darüber
sprechen weil ich diese diese Störungen
halt tagtäglich bei mir sehen und dann
würde ich gerne auch noch mal was zu Dir
sagen erstmal das sacken lassen dass wir
das mal kurz hin und her spielen können
paulita jetzt hat Heike gerade davon
gesprochen es gibt einen erheblichen
Anteil in ihrer Praxis von Leuten mit
einem großen Leidensdruck kannst du das
erstmal nachvollziehen und anerkennen
oder sagst du dieses Quatsch nein ich
glaube da sind wir uns einig ehrlich ich
glaube es gibt viele Menschen die Leiden
in der Gesellschaft aufgrund von der Art
und Weise wie Sexualität und Pornografie
gehandhabt wird so und ich glaube da
sind wir uns ah nicht dass da was
passieren muss meine Antwort darauf ist
Aufklärung muss stattfindet wir müssen
mehr über Pornografie reden wir müssen
mehr über Sexualität reden genau ich
glaube da finden wir uns alle zusammen
das ist auch schön Sexualität und
Pornografie ist immer noch ein Tabuthema
auch und wir denken dass wir oh so frei
sind und tatsächlich sind wir vielleicht
freier in manchen Aspekten aber wir sind
immer noch total eingeengt in die Art
und Weise wie wir mit Pornografie
umgehen wenn wir für sexuelle
Selbstbestimmung in der Gesellschaft
sorgen wollen um wenn der Staat deren
Auftrag einlösen will dann müssen wir
nicht die industriestärke regulieren wir
müssen sie fördern meine Frage
vielleicht zurück wäre ich bin ja keine
Therapeutin ich frage an euch du redest
die ganze Zeit von Verhaltensstörung und
dann wirfst du aber das Begriff der
Sucht da gibt es auch ein Unterschied
zwischen sucht und Verhaltensstörung
oder also ich bin keine Ärztin ich frage
euch warum warum reden wir von Sucht an
der Stelle weil mein Gefühl meine
Wahrnehmung ist dass man von Sucht und
Pornokonsum geredet wird wenn man will
es wird suggeriert Porno sei eine
Substanz die per se sozusagen süchtig
macht das wie als wie Heroin zum
Beispiel und ich glaube dass das nicht
stimmt also heroin ist tatsächlich
wissenschaftlich geprüft das schaffen
eine Sucht so dein Körper braucht dieses
Zeugs bei Porno ist es nicht es ist eine
Verhaltensstörung nicht eine eine
physische sucht alex hat sich so
angefühlt
also habe ich das richtige Frage ist ist
eine sucht nicht eine Verhaltensstörung
also wie das Wort was da schon drin
steckt also ich kann das nicht anmaßen
ich bin kein Therapeut ein
Verhaltensstörung ist wenn ich im
Verhalten mich so
gestört präsentiere in meinem Umfeld
dass mein Leben aus den Fugen gerät also
ich nicht mehr sozial kompatibel bin und
das ist ja genau bei mir passiert also
ich habe mich stundenlang in meinem
Zimmer eingeschlossen teilweise
wochenlang habe nur drei Stunden in der
Nacht geschlafen Freunde haben sich
Sorgen gemacht konnten es nicht
einordnen ich sah aus wie ein Haufen
Scheiße also ich hatte auf jeden Fall
eine Verhaltensstörung und ich würde
auch sagen dass wenn ich Pornografie was
ich immer mal wieder ein paar Tage
geschafft habe so an die Seite zu
schieben dass ich die die diese dieser
Drang zu flüchten verlagert hat also ich
habe auf jeden Fall auch ein Problem
jetzt bin ich hier super offen auch mit
Alkoholkonsum darum trinke ich jetzt
auch Alkohol weil wenn ich einmal an der
an Fläschchen Sippe dann ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass ich zehn
Flaschen Bier trinken kann statt eine
und nicht Stopp sagen kann sehr sehr
groß genauso war es in meiner Jugendzeit
mit Cannabis so und ich beobachte
einfach nur bei mir selber aus der
persönlichen Warnung heraus dass da
genau dasselbe passiert bei Pornografie
ich ich ich nippe an etwas und dann
zieht es mich rein und vor allen Dingen
wenn ich mich schlecht fühle will ich
mir irgendwie einen Kick holen nämlich
gut fühlen lässt und ich glaube was ich
in meiner laienhaftigkeit zu wissen
vermag dass Dopamin eine große Rolle
spielt das heißt ein Botenstoff der
ausgeschüttelt wird in mir der mich gut
fühlen lässt und mich reinzieht und
immer mehr immer mehr und das Problem
bei Pornografie war dann bei mir
du ziehst dir halt einen Film rein
irgendwas der eine Film halt nicht mehr
genug und dann siehst du den zweiten
Film rein und weil der zweite Film
vielleicht nicht mehr heftig genug ist
siehst du dir den dritten rein der dann
irgendwie
Gangbang ist und so und in dieser das
Problem bei dieser Tube Pornografie ist
die wir heutzutage haben da zieht es
einem halt richtig rein und man sieht
halt sich immer krassere krasseres Zeug
rein aber alles also was ich sagen will
dann bin ich fertig ich habe das
beobachtet dieses diese
Verhaltensstörung auch in anderen
Bereichen bei anderen
Konsumverhalten die eben schon als Sucht
kategorisiert sind offiziell also
geliebt auch nicht an der Pornografie
selbst sondern es liegt an deinem Umgang
damit oder wie du mit ohne angenehmen
Gefühlen umgehst aber ist das mit
Alkohol nicht dasselbe klar aber du
nutzt die Pornografie dafür und
verteufelst dann das Medium nein
das problematisch wenn du sagst und dann
der nächste Film und der nächste Film
ist ja weil man sich in der Regel dazu
selbst befriedigt und dann sich noch mal
noch mal als klar es geht um Dopamin es
geht darum dieses gute Gefühl zu
erreichen und auf der Jagd danach ist
das stimmt
aber du könntest auch die Fantasie
nutzen machst du aber nicht machen viele
Menschen nicht weil es leichter ist
nicht was pornografisches anzusehen
anstatt den Kopf zu benutzen
ich kann es wenn ich diese diese urges
manchmal habe und mir geht's schlecht
ich habe schon super oft probiert wenn
ich dann unter der Dusche stehe und ich
fühle mich irgendwie geil will ich mich
jetzt selbst befriedigen nee ich mache
es dann nach der Dusche ziehe ich mir
dann auch noch mal lieber ein Porno rein
und manchmal ist das wie ferngesteuert
ich kann dann nicht mich entscheiden in
dem Moment
ich mache es in der Dusche mit meinen
Gedanken sondern ich bevorzuge den Porno
weil es mich da rein zieht aber was ich
super deutlich hier raus kristallisieren
möchte dass ich Pornografie überhaupt
nicht verteufelt ich möchte einfach nur
darauf aufmerksam machen dass
wenn
jemand der das jetzt sieht Probleme im
Leben hat die Schmerzen verursachen dass
das ein eine Welt ist und die man sich
reinflüchten kann und diese Schmerzen
nicht zu fühlen und dann kann es
verhaltenstechnisch zu Problemen kommen
und das hat nichts mit Geld aber Social
Media Sport und so weiter ich glaube das
ist das relevante wir nehmen jetzt
erstmal an dass dass du ein Problem ich
sag mal mit Pornografie hattest nicht
vielleicht nicht wegen Fotografie wir
können ja dann den Begriff sucht auch
erstmal in Klammern beiseite legen sonst
streiten wir uns hier ewig über den
Begriff das brauchen wir auch nicht mal
wir erkennen jetzt erstmal an du hattest
mit Pornografie ein Problem immer kannst
du das Nachvollziehen ja total also es
gibt Pornografie die auf jeden Fall
denke ich schädlich ist die Gewalt
verherrlicht und so weiter die eben für
einen zu hohen die dopaminenausschuss
oder was auch immer sagt aber wäre es ja
nicht sinnvoll beispielsweise
Alternativen zu finden die weniger dafür
sorgen dass du dich so reingezogen
fühlst sondern dass man irgendwie ja
vielleicht ein bisschen sanft daran geht
es gibt ja ganz viele verschiedene Arten
von Pornos man kann ja nicht Porno
verallgemeinernd und sagen jeder Porno
ist gleich und vielleicht hast Du ich
weiß nicht welche Pornos du geschaut das
aber einfach die falschen Pornos
geschaut und es gibt natürlich die
Möglichkeit das zu regulieren aber ich
glaube nicht dass es so ein kleines ja
Nein fällt da wirklich was bringen also
ich bin es immer easy Umgang aber super
gut aber wie willst du das in dieser
Tube Pornografie Welt realisieren wo du
das eine Genre neben dem anderen siehst
und der Algorithmus mittlerweile dir
auch schon das ausspielst spielt was du
vielleicht am häufigsten geklickt hast
und dir noch krassere Vorschläge macht
also das ganz ganz schwer Deine
Entscheidung zu treffen so ich will das
jetzt nicht gucken definitiv schwierig
und ich bin total bei dir das was ich
jetzt nimmt es nicht persönlich ich
glaube du bist halt vom Grundsatz her
ein Mensch der schnell in eine Sucht
verfällt egal welche sucht es halt ist
da ist es natürlich ungünstig also auf
so einer Rückseite zu landen und
natürlich ist der Reiz nach mehr höher
schneller weiter den will natürlich jede
jemand es gibt Menschen die gehen halt
so wie du es gerade gesagt hast easy und
nö ich bleib bei meinem und dann gibt's
halt die Menschen wie du die bis zum
Exitus hinausgehen wollen was vollkommen
in Ordnung aber schnell natürlich zu
etwas krankhaften führen kann denn ich
glaube da müssen wir halt einfach
unterscheiden weil natürlich stimme ich
dir zu ja es ist vielleicht nicht
sinnvoll sich mit 14 15 Jahren ein
Gangbang anzuschauen aber ich sehe das
auch nicht als krankhafte Veranlagung
weil es gibt ja auch einfach Menschen
die daran Spaß haben jetzt haben wir
jetzt haben wir relativ viel darüber
gesprochen was potenziell für Gefahren
im Raum stehen wie du sie beschrieben
hast Alex die du damit verbunden hast
vielleicht können wir auch mal paulita
auf die Ebene kommen was möglicherweise
eine positive Auswirkung von Pornokonsum
sein kann oder überhaupt von Pornos
gerne also ich glaube porn die bietet
den Menschen in einem Raum in einem
sicheren kontrollierbaren Rahmen eben
rauszufinden was mag ich ich kann mir
ein Porno vielleicht stehe ich darauf
aber ich will jetzt nicht direkt den
Sexclub Rennen und damit Menschen
irgendwie das ausprobieren soll ich
gucke ich mir erstmal an im Wohnzimmer
ich denke mir so was macht das mit mir
Besitzer bei mir ja vielleicht möchte
ich das tatsächlich ausleben aber ich
denke mir so nö ich gucke das gerne aber
dabei kann es auch bleiben oder ich
denke mir vielleicht auch nicht meins
und das ist eine sehr gesunde Art und
Weise eben mit der eigenen Sexualität
sich auszutoben sexuelle Aufklärung ja
es kann sexuelle Aufklärung oder
sexuelle Erforschung sozusagen
Orientierungshilfe Orientierungshilfe ja
vielleicht es kann natürlich auch zum
Beispiel in Dialog mit einem Partner
einer Partnerin eröffnen wenn ich
vielleicht was was neues ausprobieren
will aber ich weiß nicht genau wie ich
das Frage dann sage ich wollen wir uns
vielleicht zusammen was angucken ich
weiß nicht ob du drauf stehst aber ich
finde es interessant und kann das
sozusagen der erste Schritt sein wie man
darüber redet also Pornografie kann uns
behilflich sein einfach besser
gründlicher über Sexualität zu regeln
und mehr darüber zu erfahren über uns
selbst und unseren Partnerinnen zu
kennenzulernen wenn du wenn ich darauf
reagieren darf ich bin da total bei dich
nach vorne wenn du es nicht als eine
fluchtwelt nutzt anders Gegenbeispiel
Schokolade oder was Gegenbeispiel aus
der aus der aus der Praxis ich habe mir
sehr viele Genres angeschaut habe mir
auch zum Beispiel Domina Filme
angeschaut und vor dem vor dem Screen
fand ich fand ich es geil und ich bin
natürlich irgendwann mit meiner
Problematik als es völlig aus dem Urlaub
gelaufen ist auch mal auf die Frage
kommen wie wäre es denn ich hatte das
vorhin schon mal erwähnt wenn ich mal
ein paar Sachen ausprobiere also bin ich
mal zu einer Domina gegangen zwei drei
mal und habe dann verschiedene Dinge
ausprobiert und festgestellt dass viele
Dinge mir da gar nicht gefallen also die
ich mir auf dem Bildschirm als geil
suggeriert habe also von daher finde ich
das noch ein bisschen schwierig zu sagen
gut ich gucke mir das und dann
bin ich vielleicht
rausprobiert du hast festgestellt okay
ist doch nichts für mich und dann hast
du es gelassen ja was ist schlecht daran
aber die
Illusion also das Verhältnis in dem ich
mir diese Filme von dem Screen
angeschaut habe und aus diesem Akt der
Verzweiflung dann ist einfach mal
ausprobiert habe da steht nicht im
Verhältnis also die Filme sind auf einer
Skala von hier bis Tokyo und die dreimal
das die ich bei einer Domina war waren
dann der Akt der Verzweiflung und dann
habe ich zum Glück rausgefunden okay das
Genre
da habe ich mir so viele Filme angeguckt
und mich da so dran gelabert im echten
Leben nicht abgeholt warum bist du nach
vorne gegangen ich bin nach vorne
gegangen weil ich da zustimme also es
kann auf jeden Fall sein dass man diese
Erfahrung macht dass du merkst okay das
gefällt mir im Porno das gefällt mir
nicht da bin ich genauso also ich habe
auch schon gemerkt ich mag total gerne
step dead Pornos und trotzdem würde ich
niemals mit meinem Stiefvater schlafen
also das ist finde ich vollkommen in
Ordnung nachvollziehbar ja genau ich
finde besser auch ganz ganz wichtig ist
was halt wirklich sehr oft vergessen
wird halt das was wir da machen wenn wir
vor oder hinter der Kamera stehen ist
dass wir
demjenigen der sich das anschaut das
kann auch mal auf Deutsch gesagt in die
Hose gehen ja aber eine Illusionswelt
verschaffen möchten und wir möchten
Ihnen abholen da wo er selbst für sich
niemals hingehen kann weil er eventuell
verheiratet ist zwei Kinder hat der Hund
Katze Maus das was man halt einfach an
Alltagsproblemen hat ja und es gibt ihm
einen Moment der Zuflucht und das was
vor der Kamera läuft ich glaube das
Schlimmste mir zu das ist das was wir
machen das ist wir spielen jemanden ein
Szenario vor und möchten ihn einladen
daran mit teil zu haben ich weiß das
hört sich total bescheuert an und viele
sehen damit hallo aber so ist es
letztendlich wir teilen unsere
Leidenschaft und für mich ist immer der
Grundkonsens dass ich sage Mensch ist
doch schön wenn sich das im besten Falle
auch noch Mann und Frau zusammen
angucken die beide wieder zueinander
finden happy family und das ist
letztendlich der Grundkonsens was ich
halt natürlich gibt es solche Sachen und
das ist dramatisch und dass wir immer
höher schneller weiter und verschiedene
Sexpraktiken aber da müssen wir auch
diskutieren was ist normal wer bestimmt
im Sexuellen Normalität das ist ganz
schwierig das kannst Du fast nicht
machen das einzige was ich halt sage
okay Kinder sollten kein Hardcore Porno
zu Gesicht bekommen ich bin zum Beispiel
mal mich vielleicht das unbeliebt mit
ich bin zum Beispiel auch dafür dass
durchaus auch 16-Jährige bestimmte
Pornos sehen dürfen weil sind wir doch
mal ganz ehrlich Aufklärung in der
Schule wo fangen wir denn da an bei
Bienchen und Blümchen die Eltern ober
peinlich mit denen darüber zu sprechen
und da bin ich dabei das natürlich nicht
es vermittelt werden soll dass Analsex
Gangbangs oder sonst etwas etwas
Normales sind für das erste Mal
Geschlechtsverkehr weil ich finde man
sollte erstmal Erfahrungen sammeln und
sich langsam irgendwo reingucken aber
ich finde auch dass
gewisse pornoografie mit 16 vollkommen
in Ordnung ist jetzt würde ich gerne mal
eure Meinung dazu wissen schreibt es mir
gerne mal in die Kommentare was sind
denn eure Erfahrungen mit Pornos gucken
war das für euch irgendwie aufklärerisch
habt ihr euch da neu orientieren können
was eine Orientierungshilfe oder habt
ihr eher verstörendes gesehen hat euch
das irgendwie geschadet schreibt es auch
gerne mal in die Kommentare wie ihr mit
Pornos umgegangen seid vielleicht früher
vielleicht heute was hat sich geändert
da habe ich sehr gespannt und jetzt
haben wir ganz viel mal gesammelt was es
auch positive Effekte haben kann wenn
man Pornokonsum eben nicht stigmatisiert
sondern ganz offen damit umgehen kann
aber wenn wir und das ist ja auch ein
bisschen das Thema dieser Sendung wenn
wir über Regulierungsfragen reden müssen
wir auch mal sagen da reden wir vor
allem über Schutz von Minderjährigen und
in Deutschland sind halt Pornos für U18
verboten es gibt ein Gesetz dafür und es
gibt es verschiedene
Landesmedienanstalten die sondern für
die Durchsetzung dieses Gesetzes
zuständig die nun sagen okay wer als
Porno pornografischer Anbieter eben ist
nicht hinbekommt U18 auszuschließen dann
müssen wir jetzt mit der mit der Keule
kommen in Teilen zumindest also dann
reden wir über Netzsperren wenn man eben
nicht nachweisen kann dass nur über
18-Jährige das Konsumieren du wolltest
was dazu sagen was die Medienanstalten
sagen bzw die die die Jugendkommission
für Medien genau die sagen nicht nur
Minderjährigen sollen sich keine
Pornoseiten die sagen jeder Erwachsene
der sich ein Porno schauen möchte möchte
bitte mit dem Ausweis zur Post und sagen
gute schönen Tag ich bin der Max Müller
und ich möchte jetzt gerne mir ein
Hentai Porno angucken und dann sagt der
Mensch an der Post ja Herr Müller viel
Spaß beim Wechseln mit dem Handzeichen
Porno das ist eine eingrätzung der
sexuelle Selbstbestimmung das ist absurd
aber auf der anderen Seite paulita wir
haben dieses Gesetz und da sagen viele
wenn wir ein Gesetz haben müssen wir es
auch durchsetzen aber das ist das
Paragraph 184 sagt nicht dass ich mich
mit meinem Ausweis identifizieren muss
das sagt die Jugendkommission das Gesetz
sagt nur 18-Jährige sollten kein Zugang
zu Pornos darüber können wir generieren
was ist die bestmögliche technologische
Lösung um eben zu verhindern ich bin
total bei ich glaube wir sind alle einig
dass achtjährige keine Hardcore Pornos
gucken sollten was ist denn auch mit
Datenschutz zum Beispiel also wenn da
irgendwelche Datenbanken generiert
werden mit Name Personalausweis ich
stehe auf Analpornos und auf die und die
Pornos und auf
Natursekt nach dann muss es ein Lied
geben dieser Datenbank und dann gibt es
riesen Probleme also ich frage mich wie
das umgesetzt werden soll also deswegen
auch wieder ich finde das total gut
diesen Diskurs den wir hier führen weil
es geht am Ende um Aufklärung und
alleine dieser Diskurs trägt zur
Aufklärung bei ich glaube das ist so das
Kernelement ich habe gemerkt ihr seid
alle wenn ich das richtig verstanden
habe bitte Hand heben wenn es jemand
anders sieht ihr seid dagegen dass
Menschen alle Menschen die Pornos gucken
wollen im Internet sich mit Ausweis beim
Postamt ausweisen müssen Heikes ist das
auch so sehe ich sehr kritisch auch von
den also ich bin hinterlassen sehr viele
Spuren im Internet ne und gerade wenn
man im Sozialen Medien uns bewegen sind
wir natürlich sehr transparent das ist
uns oftmals gar nicht so bewusst und da
sehe ich auch Schwierigkeiten jetzt
müssen wir natürlich nur Fragen also es
gibt ja diese Vorschläge es gibt ja
diese Vorschläge von von namhaften
Politikern und Politikerinnen die das
durchsetzen wollen die dann auch mit
Netzsperren und so weiter drohen die
wiederum haben auch diesen heute nicht
hier aber es gibt ja durchaus Menschen
Eltern in Deutschland die sagen ja
verdammt noch mal also natürlich muss
das so gemacht werden weil ich will
meine Kinder schützen was antwortet ihr
diesen Eltern eigene Nase ja wirklich
erstmal an die eigene Nase also nochmal
ich bin dabei ja und ich sehe das auch
superkritisch wie wir gerade gesagt
haben mit Ausweis und so weil wo ist die
wo ist die Privatsphäre wenn das
wirklich mal wie wir gerade schon
besprochen haben liegt wird oder sonst
irgendwas da hängen Existenzen dran das
geht einfach nicht das ist schwierig zu
regulieren ein 16-Jähriger kann diese
Netzsperre die med innerhalb 30 Sekunden
mit einer VPN umgehen absolut aber ist
jetzt versetzt euch bitte mal kurz nur
damit wir das mal klar ziehen in die
Lage einer Mutter die sagt moment mal
also wir haben zum Beispiel
Alkoholverbot für unter 16-Jährige das
heißt wenn mein Kind in Supermarkt geht
und mit einer Flasche Wodka rauskommt
dann kann ich zum Supermarkt gehen und
sagen dich zeige ich an weil du gegen
das Gesetz gehandelt hast die selbe
Mutter sagt pass mal auf Pornografie für
Minderjährige ist verboten aber mein
Kind kann da einfach hingehen und sich
die Pornografie holen also müssen wir
das verbieten was antwortet ihr der
Mutter muss man sagen leider lebt sie
ein bisschen in der illusorischen Welt
wenn sie denkt dass ihr 16-jähriger
Jugendlicher Jugendliche noch nie mit
Alkohol in Berührung gekommen wäre oder
15 okay ab 15 haben mit 16 darf man
gewisse Sachen dass sie noch nie mit
Alkohol in Berührung gekommen wären die
sind mit Alkohol klar natürlich ist es
verboten aber die sind damit in
Berührung gekommen das gleiche gilt auch
für Pornografie und deswegen müssen wir
sowohl Eltern als auch die Jugendlichen
selber vielleicht auch schon die Kinder
aufklären damit eben genauso Sachen
14-Jährige was die haben keine Ahnung
was ein Gangbang ist und dann sagt aber
vielleicht jemand hey wir machen heute
Nachmittag bei mir im Gangbang hast du
Bock drauf ich bin vielleicht verknallt
in die Person dann sage ich ja klar ich
mache alles was du sagst wenn ich aber
meinem 14 15-Jährigen erklärt habe ich
muss es nicht zeigen um Gottes Willen
aber erklärt habe was ist ein Gangbang
kann es sich dann eben genau dagegen
entscheiden und sagen was geht mit dir
ab auf gar keinen Fall wir müssen so
viel mehr Aufklärungsarbeiten also ich
sage jetzt wir aber der Staat na wie als
Gesellschaft müssen Aufklärung leisten
weil jetzt werden wahrscheinlich einige
Eltern und Heike bald auch noch was
sagen einige Eltern sagen ja toll also
bleibt jetzt an uns hängen also ich muss
mich jetzt informieren was soll ich denn
jetzt machen also ich finde es sollte
einfach an verschiedenen Stellen einfach
Maßnahmen erfolgen also ganz wichtig
finde ich ist dass man einfach eine
offene Diskussion führt und damit nicht
mit erhobenen Zeigefinger und sagen dass
nicht über Pornografie ist es halt so
also man darf es nicht ins schlechte
aber auch nicht nur sagen das ist super
es kann auch sexuelle Fantasien rauben
in dem Sinne dass es sie ersetzt dass
man einfach gar keine Fantasie mehr
entwickelt sondern dass man diesen
Pornofilm hat ne also man muss einfach
schauen das waren sowohl auf Elternseite
ich habe eine 12-jährige Tochter und ich
habe ihr auch ganz offen gesagt also ich
bekomme Screenshots alle 20 Minuten und
ich kann einmal in der Woche gehe ich da
mal kurz rüber das weiß sie und ich
möchte nicht dass du mit deinen zwölf
Jahren pornografier schaust ich möchte
auch nicht dass du Gewalt
verherrlichtende Sachen schaust und ich
möchte auch nicht dass du Candy Crash
die ganze Zeit spielst du kannst ein
paar Sachen mit deinen Freunden chatten
und du kannst Phase 6 Vokabeln lernen
oder so etwas ja also sowas sowieso aber
so oder weil nach Geschenkideen do it
yourself suchen aber also ich spreche
das konkret an das finde ich ganz ganz
wichtig und jetzt weiß die Sache
mit den Screenshots mit dieser
überwachungs das ist die Funktion auch
wenn meine Tochter sich eine App
runterladen möchte muss ich die
freigeben und dann entscheide ich schon
ob meine Tochter Instagram kriegt oder
nicht in diesem Fall nicht ja aber auf
der anderen Seite wissen wir dass
Verhältnis präventivem Maßnahmen und das
ist so etwas ja dass man auch von
staatlicher Seite bestimmte
Zugangsbeschränkungen macht durchaus ein
Effekt hat das sehen wir zum Beispiel
beim Rauchen beim Alkohol ist der Staat
dann weniger konsequent aber beim
Rauchen haben wir über viele Verhältnis
präventive Maßnahmen mittlerweile ein
deutlich geringeren Anteil von Nikotin
Süchtigen in unserer Gesellschaft durch
Limitierung des Zugriffs das macht es
unbequem das macht Sand ins Getriebe und
dann und das kann natürlich durchaus
auch dazu führen dass der ein oder
andere auch abgehalten wird deswegen ist
sagen wir mal die Umsetzung extrem
schwierig im Internet auf der anderen
Seite muss man sich schon Gedanken
machen ob auch von staatlicher Seite
also ob das nicht nur bei den Eltern
oder bei der Schule bleibt dass man
vielleicht auch der Samen mal staatliche
Interventionen macht die dann eben
diesen Zugang beschränkt im Sinne von
Verhältnis präventivem Maßnahmen
Antworten könnt was meinst du damit also
wie was heißt das konkret naja das schon
in irgendeiner Weise zumindest also so
solche Hinweise außer dieses ich bin 18
jetzt no also dass man ich kann nicht
die technische Umsetzung machen und ich
weiß auch dass man relativ schnell Wege
findet um das ganze zu vermeiden ich
finde das hat eine Signalwirkung auch in
der Bevölkerung wo oftmals gesagt wird
ach das ist ja alles in Ordnung oder
sowas seitdem wir ein Smartphone hat ist
ruhig im Zimmer ja da haben wir gar
keinen Robo gar keinen brauchen wir uns
nicht mehr bemühen oder sowas das ist
einfach ein Bewusstsein schafft ja es
ist eine Lust Mittel aber im Überdosis
genossen kann das eben auch tatsächlich
Schäden verursachen und deswegen wie man
das genau umsetzen bin ich der
Technologe aber ich wünsche dir stärkere
Signale also es in anderen Bereichen ja
beim Nikotin beim Alkohol durchaus
Regulativ
gearbeitet wird und das hat manchmal
immer es unbequem zu machen oder ein
bisschen die Hürde zu erhören kann
durchaus ja etwas erreichen so und bevor
jetzt ihr seid sofort wieder alle dran
aber immer habe ich schon lange nicht
gehört und würde gerne mal hören was was
denkst du darüber größere Signalwirkung
Präventivmaßnahmen staatliche
Limitierung zumindest was deine Antwort
ich finde den Grundgedanken der
Limitierung gar nicht so schlecht also
ich will auch dafür dass man zum
Beispiel Pornos hat die FSK 12 sind FSK
16 sind FSK 18 sind das wäre ja schon
irgendwo eine Einordnung oder
Limitierung aber eben ich finde diese
Signalwirkung ist komplett zu regulieren
und beispielsweise ja Ausweis
hinterzulegen oder irgendwie anderweitig
Daten abzugeben das sendet dass er das
Signal dass es etwas ja gefährliches ist
oder dass alle Pornos eben schlecht sind
ich finde es schwierig die also alle
Pornoseite an sich so zu verteufeln ich
bin ganz bei dir ehrlich gesagt wenn wir
die gesamte industriever Täufern so wie
du es gesagt hast was wir schaffen ist
das viel weniger Leute die auch ein
ästhetischen Anspruch ein ethischen
Anspruch haben am Pornografie dass die
das auch machen können je mehr wir diese
Hindernisse die du nennst du vergleichst
Nikotin und Pornografie ich glaube es
ist schwierig ne Gottchen ist wirklich
ja es ist ein suchmittel es kann Zero
gehen soll ja das ist nicht das Gleiche
es ist so es wird doch Pornografie
gleichgesetzt mit Gewalt verherrlichen
ich finde das alles sehr heikel und ich
glaube ganz gesund gleich fertig
je mehr wir diese Hindernisse stellen
die du gerade nennst und denkst so ich
verstehe den Gedanken wo du herkommst
und ich mich ganz wie gesagt
nachvollziehen ich glaube das ist nicht
die Lösung Ebene es gab 12 nicht FSK 16
andere Arten und Weise diese Pornografie
zu kategorisieren in dem Filmgenre
einfach rein zu nehmen das würde helfen
dass es mehr Diversität gibt dass mehr
Leute einfach unterschiedliche Pornos
machen das unterschiedliche Körper
Sexualitäten Sexualpraktiken
und und und eben nicht nur Pornos
gemacht werden die nicht nur auf den
sexuellen Reiz anspielen sondern einfach
andere Ansprüche haben und nur wir
schaffen das nur indem wir das die
wirtschaftlich einfacher machen für
Menschen je mehr Hindernisse wieder du
striest Stellen desto ich sage jetzt mal
eng wird das Angebot sein jetzt darf
erst mal Alex Antworten ich bin jetzt
auch nach vorne gegangen weil ich so auf
einer Linie mit dem Diversität in
Pornografie ist also das wenn ich was
mir auch total gefehlt hat ich habe auch
mittlerweile feministische Pornos
gesehen also aus einem anderen aus einer
anderen Perspektive Produktionen gesehen
die tatsächlich auch einen anderen
Effekt haben suggeriere ich mir jetzt
mal selbst was sie mit meinem Gehirn
machen das ist total toll und ich glaube
das ist das ist ein guter Weg und auch
darüber Aufklärung zu machen gar nicht
so in your face Aufklärung sondern durch
Produktionen die eben wirklich dann auf
eine andere war Art und Weise aufklären
ich glaube was mir hier gerade fehlt bei
der ganzen Diskussion wir vergleichen
die reale Welt mit der digitalen Welt
und die Signalwirkung finde ich auch
super gut wenn es irgendwelche Blogger
gibt oder so aber machen wir uns nichts
vor ich glaube dass wenn die Blogger bei
den großen Pornoseiten am Start sind
kommt der nächste Server der einfach auf
einem auf einem auf einem anderen auf
einem anderen Insel gebaut wird und dann
sind die Pornos wieder zugänglich auch
ohne diese Blocker und das hat man in
der realen Welt nicht wenn ich als
Minderjähriger Alkohol kaufen will dann
muss ich entweder einen 18-jährigen
18-Jährige finden die mir das kauft oder
irgendwie mich durch mit einem
gefälschten passt es ist das sind
krassere Hürden als einfach im Netz mir
eine andere URL rauszusuchen die einfach
noch nicht geblockt ist wir haben jetzt
also ich glaube 27 Mal das Wort
Aufklärung gehört heute vollkommen
richtig sind wir uns auch alle einig
aber vielleicht könnt ihr noch mal
konkreter werden und sagen was heißt
denn das
Sexualkunde bessere Lehrpläne politische
Anstrengungen brauchen wir einen
sexualkunde-minister ein Ministerium was
ich damit besser auseinandersetzt also
ich suche wirklich also wir sehen haben
das Problem erkannt wir wollen
vulnerable Menschen schützen wenn sie
schützenswert sind wie bitte Paul Dieter
okay ich bin nicht der Expertin aber ich
fange an und bestimmt könnt ja weiter
ergänzen eine inklusive lustorientierte
sexual Aufklärung in Schulen das heißt
sexuell Aufklärung ist oft Penis im
Vagina S6 dann wird man schwanger wie
werde ich nicht schwanger und wie werde
ich nicht Geschlecht krank so das ist
eine sehr im Gesicht auf Sexualität auch
wichtig aber wie gesagt es muss
Sexualität als als Lust dargestellt
werden es muss inklusiv sein dass das
wie gesagt unterschiedliche Identitäten
Sexualität in Sexualpraktiken müssen
behandelt werden und es muss darüber
gesprochen werden was ist Pornografie
absolut das muss die Schule muss das
anders aufbauen wenn wir zum Beispiel im
Berliner Lehrplan anschauen bereits in
der ersten Klasse Grundschule ist
eigentlich Sexualkunde mit auf dem Plan
und ich weiß nicht wie es bei euch weil
ich kann von meiner Schulzeit reden ich
hatte
Aufklärungsunterricht relativ früh dann
noch mal 9 Klasse dann noch mal
Oberstufe und so und dann muss man
schauen dass man daraus vielleicht
Projektwochen macht ne wenn Sexualität
und Lust und Anlass nämlich mit rein
nimmt Biologie liegt da relativ nah wir
können in Ethik Bedingungen für an
pornoseits besprechen zum Beispiel wir
können in Geschichte die Geschichte von
was sind Gesetze gewesen wie war das
politisch und so weiter besprechen wir
können in deutsch englisch französisch
Literatur dazu lesen also das ist
fächerübergreifend machbar aber dafür
bräuchten wir Erwachsene die sich trauen
über dieses Thema zu sprechen das
anzusprechen und nicht hinter
vorgehaltener haben dann Liebe machen
nennen oder so du hast wirklich den
Nagellack auf den Kopf getroffen ich
glaube das ist ein riesengroßes Problem
unserer Gesellschaft ist halt diese
unfassbar schreckliche Doppelmoral das
Menschen halt einfach hingehen und sagen
da sprechen wir mal nicht drüber ja aber
sich dann auf der anderen Seite
beschweren wenn dann halt irgendwelche
schlimmen Dinge passieren und das finde
ich persön mich total schlimm weil es
ist nicht Sex ist ja nichts schlimmes
und diese ganze Sex workerschaft ist ja
nicht schlimmes wir haben einen
Industriezweig gepickt womit wir Leuten
in erster Linie Freude bereiten das ist
manchmal ausgenutzt wird klar logisch
aber die Aufklärung muss da sein
erfreulicherweise stehen viele von euch
relativ weit vorne eigentlich steht ja
alle weit vorne noch nicht alle im
Kompromiss fällt drin alex ist so schon
sehr nah in der Mitte mal sehen ob wir
euch jetzt durch Kompromissvorschläge
noch ein bisschen weiter
auseinandertreiben können oder noch
näher zusammenbringen können erstmal die
Frage an euch nachdem ihr das ganze
jetzt gehört habt was glaubt ihr wäre
die richtige Maßnahme welche
Kompromisslinie habt ihr gerade im Kopf
schreibt uns in die Kommentare wer weiß
vielleicht trifft sich ja die ein oder
andere Meinung hier dann genau in der
Mitte also wir sind der Kompromiss Runde
ich würde euch einen Vorschlag machen
ich habe jetzt aus der Diskussion ein
bisschen mitgenommen
Absatz Kompromissvorschlag oder sollen
wir Vorschlag für eine Maßnahme wäre
eine FSP ne also eine freiwillige
Selbstkontrolle Porno wie es bei der FSK
gibt oder FSF oder für die Gaming
Industrie gibt es das also Labels die
einem Orientierung geben können dass es
eher Blümchensex und das hier ist super
Hardcore und dann kann man vorher als
User Userin Eltern Start vielleicht
sogar auch schon als Produzent
Produzenten Vorhersagen das ist so eine
Richtung
wer das initiiert ist natürlich die
große Frage in dem internationalen Markt
vollkommen klar aber man könnte ja
zumindest darauf hinwirken dass man sagt
hey wir in Deutschland fangen mal an wir
verteilen Labels vielleicht setzt sich
das mit einem guten Beispiel fort also
mein Vorschlag wäre wir machen eine
freiwillige Selbstkontrolle Porno wenn
ihr sagt Bruder Vorschlag gehe ich einen
Schritt vor wenn ihr sagt ist Quatsch
geht den Schritt zurück
gut ganz ehrlich so nah waren sich die
contestanten lange nicht mehr
Corona gibt es ja Gott sei Dank nicht
mehr genau so jetzt könnt ihr bitte in
eure Gruppe immer die Köpfe
zusammenstecken und mal überlegen und
einen Vorschlag raushauen wie wir
vielleicht uns dann alle gleich zum
Ringelpietz treffen
[Musik]
aber auch also die ganzen Armaturen die
ihre Sachen hochladen relativ einfach
die Frage an euch was haltet ihr davon
Labels zu verteilen im Internet
vielleicht grüne orangene und rote dass
man weiß okay das ist wirklich super
Hardcore das ist irgendwie die Gangbang
Rap Fantasy und das da ist der
Blümchensex dass man eine gewisse
Orientierung hat vielleicht auch für
Filterprogramme dann für Eltern ist das
besser als eine Netzsperre oder
schlechter schreibt uns gerne in die
Kommentare technologisch halt
standardisiert werden
welche Gruppe möchte anfangen ihr wart
zuerst fertig also dürft ihr anfangen
also drei Schritt Programm
erstens anstatt Sperre wollen wir Filter
standardisieren das heißt die Plattform
können freiwillig auf ihrem Plattform
eben diesen Filter anlegen das kann man
das muss standardisiert werden damit
alle Devices das haben
und diese Filtern sind viel schwieriger
umzugehen als diese Sperre die wie
gesagt jeder Zwölfjähriger umgehen kann
so Nummer eins Nummer zwei Förderung von
Pornografie und das heißt aktuell ist es
so in Deutschland dass alle
Förderrichtlinien also von einem
förderanstalten
expliziert eine Klausel haben die sagt
es werden keine pornografischen oder
gewaltverherrlichenden Inhalten
gefördert das sind Gewalt und
Pornografie gleichgestellt komisch aber
nichtsdestotrotz wenn wir diese
Richtlinien ändern dann könnten andere
Menschen irgendwie ein Projekt mit
visagästhetischen und anderen Ansprüche
eine Geschichte wie du vorhin meintest
könnte sich bewerben oder nicht ist eine
andere Frage aber das dass man erstmal
überhaupt dieses Verständnis das
Pornografie was ist was stattlich nichts
erlaubt ist das müssen wir erstmal
ändern also eine Filmförderung für
pornografische Inhalte es braucht keine
spezifische Förderung also das super
wenn du magst für Produzenten sowieso ja
wenn es durchbox bin ich wirklich dabei
aber es reicht schon mal dass wir
einfach die dass wir Porno als Film
sehen und dass wir sagen nee ich kann
ein Horrorfilm weil der Filmförderung
anreiche können immer noch sagen gefällt
uns nicht aber ich darf nicht ein Porno
bei der vielen Förderung einreichen
drittes aber auf jeden Fall eigentlich
das Wichtigste von uns allen Aufklärung
okay das sind jetzt also es war jetzt
ein Bundle drei Maßnahmenpaket würdet
ihr sagen das ist schlau oder sagt ihr
zu kurz gedacht
ich bin dabei
das kann man so weiter denken keine
Einwände dann dürfte jetzt noch einen
kleinen Schritt nach vorne gehen zeichne
auch eine so umgekehrt was habt ihr noch
für ein Vorschlag pragmatischer Ansatz
als jetzt bei mir ehemaliger heavy porn
User es gibt ja immer diese
vorspann-videos auf den Tube Seiten na
bist du immer noch am [ __ ] komm doch
jetzt und trifft deine
Geschlechtspartner in in real life was
man Werbung ja genau diesen Vorspann
bevor der eigentliche Film losgeht und
den ab und zu in welchem Algorithmus das
müsste man dann ausverhandeln ersetzen
durch einen Vorspann der eigentlich
ähnlich funktioniert vom wording aber
der in die andere Richtung auch mal
kommuniziert und zwar sagt na immer noch
am [ __ ] meinst du dass es also ich
habe jetzt das Wort nicht parat aber
meinst du nicht dass du dass das
vielleicht ungesund ist oder schau doch
mal auf dieser Seite vorbei genau also
das müsste man dann aber dass man diesen
diesen Vorspann den jeder sieht den
niemand überspringen kann der sich zum
Porno anschaut mal
volierenderweise ersetzt durch einen
aufklärenden Hinweis und dass man
pornoplattformen dazu verpflichtet den
ab und zu zu setzen und dass man dann
sozusagen in seinem Tunnel das ab und zu
mal mitbekommt und wenn man es
vielleicht das vierte fünfte Mal
mitbekommt dass man dann vielleicht
drauf klickt und sich ein paar Infos
abholt damit so Leuten wie mir
vielleicht ein bisschen besser geholfen
ist also Aufklärung durch die Hintertür
quasi genau genau
[Gelächter]
aber das habe ich richtig verstanden ja
aber beim Autofahren wird ja zum
Beispiel auch manchmal eingespielt hey
bist schon drei Stunden am Fahren jetzt
mal eine Pause also so dass man oder
eben vielleicht auch
bei Problemen schau dir das und das an
also sagen wir mal wirklich auch die
problematische Seite mal anspricht oder
bei den Hinweis jetzt dass man in diesen
diesen Autopiloten wenn man da einmal so
eingefahren ist unterbricht in der
nutzersituation auch also
Hinweise ich nenne es mit Absicht nicht
wahrnhinweis weil soll ja nicht
abschreckend sein sondern nur kurze
Erinnerung Achtung also okay noch bei
dir so das war ja sehr konkreter
Vorschlag den man vielleicht sogar
relativ leicht sogar umsetzen könnte
Frage an euch findet die Idee gut kurze
Rückfrage käme das direkt beim ersten
Film oder wie bei Streaming-Diensten und
im Auto und nach einer gewissen
minutenanzahl wenn was läuft das ist
jetzt die Frage dass das haben selber
noch nicht beantwortet also das ist sehr
Algorithmus vielleicht kann man den so
einstellen dass eben nicht das erste
Video direkt das bekommt sondern erst
nachdem er wirklich fünf Filme gesehen
hat oder so dass dann der Bahn in weiß
es kommt und das macht natürlich
Standardmodus sondern nach einem
Zufallsmodus ich glaube das wäre
vielleicht günstig also für mich geht es
um eine Verweildauer die ich auf einer
Seite verbringe und ja es macht Netflix
auch ne guckst du noch also genau
deswegen frage ich nichts anderes es ist
letztendlich genau läuft gar nicht
weiter
also ich war überrascht
aber ich habe so ein Stück weit auch
erwartet weil ich war ja nicht so
komplett gefixt auf der einen Seite von
daher echt ein schön dass wir uns alle
näher gekommen sind ich finde es auch
total schön und ich glaube ich glaube
nicht dass wir natürlich repräsentativ
für die gesamte Gesellschaft da stehen
wir waren irgendwie schon eine homogene
Gruppe und trotzdem will ich glauben
dass es zeigt dass wir gesellschaftlich
schon im Mittel eines Kulturlandes sind
und wir wollen was ändern und es geht
wie genau ist unterschiedlich aber wir
wollen mehr über Sexualität reden
deswegen freue ich mich dass wir heute
waren und dass wir uns sehr zusammen
gekommen sind vielen Dank dass ihr euch
die Mühe gegeben habt Mühe gemacht habt
hier zusammenzukommen und wir sind
tatsächlich so nah zusammengekommen wie
glaube ich bei noch keiner anderen Folge
vorher sechs Leute im Kompromiss fehlt
das vielleicht ist es auch kein Zufall
dass wir über Pornografie gesprochen
haben dass wir alle bisschen näher
zusammengerückt sind herzlichen Dank
dafür das waren 13 Fragen danke
meine ganz persönliche Meinung ist wenn
wir über Netzsperren diskutieren dann
würden wir ja die juristische
Brechstange Auspacken die im Zweifel dem
Jugendschutz wenig hilft und sogar in
Sachen Datenschutz und überwachungs
Tendenzen mehr schaden könnte als helfen
wir freuen uns wenn Ihr 13 Fragen
gewogen bleibt hier könnt ihr unseren
Kanal abonnieren hier gibt es ein
weiteres Video von 13 Fragen und hier
gibt es ein weiteres Video zum Thema